hundreds ran in panic as a powerful
storm hit the stage crushing into the
crowds with little warnings strong winds
toppled the rigging leaving people
desperate to escape steel scaffolding
and heavy beams collapsed onto the
terrified concert goers one witness
filmed a chaotic scenes and describes
the moment the stage came down curious
police I couldn't believe it I just
swung around to catch the tarps blowing
in the wind and then just disbelief as
they try to leave the stadium hundreds
lifted heavy beams and machinery to
rescue the injured many of whom were in
the VIP section closest to the stage you
see it happens and you just ask it did
it really happen I didn't know issues
that and then she pulled me out from
underneath and I couldn't find my best
friend and she found me and I found my
mom
strangers didn't care it was like
everybody knew everybody because they
were there for one effort and I was to
make sure everybody was getting the
treatment thing he didn't take care of
emergency services had been monitoring
the concert waiting for a storm but its
severity and timing was unexpected four
people were killed and many more injured
at least 40 people that were injured and
transported to area hospitals the degree
of injuries for those people ranges from
cuts and scrapes to very serious
injuries and I would be I want to be
very frank that there is a possibility
that we could have other deaths a
memorial service honoring the victims
will be held tomorrow
Lisa Casa Sky News